ふぅーー
わたくし、はじめしゃちょー
今年
ラーメン食べません‼
うぅぅぅぅぅぅぅぅ（言葉にならない叫び）
去年私、お菓子を食べませんっていう目標を立てて一年間過ごして
別にそれは達成されました
で、今もお菓子バリバリ食べてます
何なら今すぐ食べます
バリバリお菓子は食べられるんですんけども（お菓子食べながら）
きょねｎ（咳き込み）
死にかけｔ　ウェッホ×２
去年一年間お菓子禁止普通だとむりなんですよ僕みたいな人間は
お菓子禁止なんて僕の人生終わったようなもんだったんですけど
どうやって達成したかというと
ラーメンの存在がすごいデカかったです
僕結構夜遅くまで起きる生活が続いてて
夜中までやってるお店っていうのはたいていラーメン屋さんか牛丼屋しかないんですよ
僕去年お菓子我慢しててたぶん心の支えになってたのはほぼ
ラーメンでした
深夜に行く友達と食うラーメンが最高にうまかった！
もうかけがえのない時間だったんですよ!僕にとっては‼
もう男の中の男ですよ!
何が?
ちょっ　わかんないんですけどとりあえずお菓子を食べれないっていうフラストレーションを吐き出してたのがたぶんラーメンでした
こってこての家系
いつもいっているラーメン屋さん「魂心家」っていうラーメン屋さんなんですけども
そのお店スープを飲み干すとまくり券っていうこういう券がもらえます
まくり証明書っていう
これあるとトッピングできたりラーメン一杯プレゼントとか
二十二枚あるとどんぶりがもらえたりするんですけども
僕去年の一年間でどれだけスープ飲み干したかっていうと
もう、たぶん　かなり尋常じゃないレベルです…
これほんと何枚だ？
ちょっと待って
集計中（早送り≻≻≻≻≻）
126枚です…
友達の分も合わせて
一年間で126杯のラーメンのスープを全部飲み干してます
体に悪い
たぶんお菓子より体に悪い
もうほんとにね～もうなんかラーメン（泣）
うぅ（泣）
食べたんですけど今年このままお菓子も解禁して、ラーメンも食って生活してるとたぶんほんとすぐ死にます
ふとめしゃちょーになるのは時間の問題だと思うので
ことしはらーめんを禁止させて頂きます
お菓子禁止にしたことによって僕の体に変化がありまして
お菓子食べたらおなかがふくれてご飯が食べれなかったんですけども
いまお菓子を食べてもご飯はちゃんと食べれます
ふつうにお菓子食った後でもご飯めっちゃ食べれてて
お菓子食べてもご飯はちゃんと食べれるようになってるので
そこでラーメンのスープを飲み干すんじゃなくて
もっとちゃんと他のもの食べれれば健康にはまだなるんじゃないかと思いまして
今年はラーメンを禁止させていただきます
ぐすん（鼻水）
この回数行ってると店員さんにもさすがに覚えられて
普通のお客さんラーメン食うとありがとうございました！
って行くんですけども
ぼくが帰るときはもう店員さんいつもありがとうございますっていって送ってくれるんですよ
ううぇぇぇん（泣）魂心家〜（泣）
店長さんの顔が浮かぶ
ほんとに去年はマジでお世話になりました
もうスープがほんとに油の沼ですよ
ただやっぱり飲み干すと券がもらえるって聞いちゃうと僕はやっぱ男なんで
全部飲みたくなるんですよ
もったいないじゃないですか‼
体には悪いけど
まあその結果がこれなんですけども
今年はラーメン食べません‼
ラーメン屋さんであった視聴者さんの方も多いと思います
今年も会うことはないと思う
そして「魂心家」の店員さん
あの去年一年間お世話になりました
チャマヨ丼が好きです。（チャーシューマヨネーズ丼）
もうこれラストだからねこれはもうラストですこれを食べてから今年はもうラーメンを食べません
魂心家行ったことある人たぶんこのまくり券の数のすごさは知ってると思います
マジで通ってました!ラーメン屋さん去年
お菓子を程よくたべつつでもしっかりご飯を食べる
で、その食べるご飯の内容もラーメン以外のものを食べるという形で頑張っていこうと思います
この縛りプレイ毎年続きそうだな…
いい‼、でもそれで健康になれるなら僕は我慢します
いただきます‼
はじめのナレーション）そして彼はラーメンに手を伸ばした…
ナレーション）すべての麺、すべてのスープに感謝し
ナレーション）彼は・・・
ナレーション）ラーメンに別れを告げたのであった
ウォーーーーーーーーー
じつは今年に入って結構ラーメン食べてお菓子も食べ続けて
ここ2週間で
2kg太ったぜ‼（キメ顔）